Oh God I don't have an idea for Visio
what do I do
I do whatever youtuber do when they
don't have an idea for a video still a
you know people always ask me Felix how
do you come up with ideas for videos I
don't I take it I take it mine my idea
you just go to someone's channel that
gets a lot of views for whatever reason
myself included and then you go to
videos and then you go to sort by most
popular and then you're like okay well
what do they do touch my body challenge
please I have integrity kids get
arrested that's actually awesome I'll
watch today I fail the easiest test this
is good tests are good I'll make a test
and I can also prove that I will not
fail this test because I'm very big
brain no boring okay uh I fill these
systems leave these tests
crazy games.com here we go the world's
easiest game and you guys can play along
that's so fun let's play welcome to the
world's easiest I don't care
beat me at tic-tac-toe god I hate the
music oh wow that was hard haha swim to
safety uh how was it moved the arrow
keys I don't know where safety is I did
it how can you fail a game like this is
this square the only shape with four
sides no goddamn my brain large what
state is this
[Music]
yeah Oh God
so the equation for x that is so poorly
written
I assume this is plus coz double
negative but you don't write it like
that so it's already a it's up that's 6
is the answer 6 6 times 3 is 12 divided
with 2 is no sorries 18 divided by 2 is
a 18 9 9 plus 4 is 13 so it is 6 that
true no hangman oh wow I would even put
a castle in the background I did it I'm
so big brain how many read it maybe they
read it really maybe the 5 o 12 come on
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 23 ah
it hurts why was a random Mexican what
is around the red rubber ball made of
rubber ball it's a rubber ball it could
still be it's made of red oh I got it do
woodchucks chuck wood uh I don't know
what I would chuck is but I'm gonna go
with yes
is that wrong I'm so confused how many
questions have you answered so far eight
Alaska what are you doing I'm so
confused
Dallman Dalmatians how many Dalmatians
how many one I'm not gonna count that
wait what did I get wrong I'm so annoyed
I thought they might like as a breed how
many all right yeah it's Catholic oh
that's just impossible
you couldn't possibly make me wait that
long
are you kidding me I'm so confused what
did I get wrong before essential
anniversary celebration how many years a
century is that what you're saying yeah
Wow so big brick shoot the map mob bys
shoot shoot this guy I'm getting mixed
messages here who's the boss here it's
gotta be this guy okay it was correct
thank you random Mexican thank you we
just have you found of Goodge feathers
or a pound of lead neither that one's
tough
that was real tough which one is the
United States
Oh while I bet it look at that I'm so
big brain a small plane crash and every
single person on board died select who
survived but they all died this is one
of those trick ones I'm so confused
okay I got it nice big brain which hand
your stairs soup with Oh mr. moon made
of sheets is the moon made of cheese
while this one is but not the real moon
what the hell turn on the light bulb
[Music]
I did it this is so annoying I'm so
annoyed by this what is the first word
of this sins what yeah big brain big
brain the word race car is the same
forwards backwards and upside down it's
a palindrome right racecar racecar but
not upside down that would be false yes
grammar please beware no they can't say
that word Oh No which is correct do you
want to go to the mall with John and me
or do you want to go to the mall with
John and I I never heard someone say
that I will guess this okay great
what color is round red rubber red ball
round round rubber red ball right this
round red takes like a rematch okay
you're it's on oh wow
how could you fail these tests their
word swims is the same forwards
backwards and upside down swims yeah
that was true yeah all right till the
zombies Jesus Christ brain very large I
got a save brain very big brain
ever-expanding my brain is like the
universe it just which country is bigger
England or the United States is this one
of those where they try and make England
look bigger or is it are they referring
to the picture itself okay they weren't
how am I supposed to know what is Oh God
seven plus four minus 30 Oh big Greg you
have nothing on me you break oh my god I
can't do this I can't
oh I'll still wait I'll still wait don't
worry
thank you I have the patience of a god
what there's two in two put together
[Music]
you didn't get that one did you
big brain four-letter words I'm SAP for
what is Sam I know what that means
how is like maple for maple jerks Oh God
four-letter word o for Laura uh Pluto is
how many lives I have oh there's the
questions I read them wrong before what
color is this ball
[Music]
thank God what is your favorite color
yay I had 27 flowers sadly all but 49
how many are left all of them died but
14 14 how many cups in the courts I
don't know what's the courts and never
heard court I got a goggle that come on
I don't know what a cordis Oh God
alright I'll just take the L because I
don't know N word I don't know we don't
use that metric that's so unfair
for big brain you gotta be honest if you
mess up let me know how many sides does
a square have my god
how could you fail this test how many
sides does a rectangle have is this a
trick question no how many legs does
this dog have my card I'm brig brain if
you take half of spiders legs off
because you're cruel
how many legs if spiders have led well
if I take half over spiders legs off
they'll still have four legs damn I
never thought I'd see a crippled spider
Jesus Christ how many seasons of the
year are there for my brain so large it
explodes
how many fingers are on a human hand one
two three four five all right let me see
here
yes what's the most they throw in these
like super easy questions and then they
throw you off by having like a kind of
tricky one in the middle what's more
powerful than God the devil evil itself
rich people fear having it but poor
people could be described as having it
let me see here we go in my power stance
I get it nothing right nothing's more
powerful than God or evil rich people
fear having it nothing but poor people
described as having it got'em oh they
just want to make you feel bad for
getting them right
the tricky ones wrong the word i' is
same backwards and upside then balls
Thank You Mexican thank you what shape
is this that's a mother oh god that's a
tough one
got it aqua is another word for how many
questions are there Jesus which one is
an elephant okay smarty-pants
what state is that as ticks as I side
down also known as a great haircut how
many sides this is cube have six eight
oh yeah I knew that is that it
I'm gonna do caps just to be safe yeah a
man wants to marry his widows sister can
he a widow sister what does that make
him his widows sister widow that means
wait no cuz he's dead that was good I
like that one click stop it stop it ah
are we gonna are we gonna stop yes how
many days are July 31 big brain we have
this knuckle thing in school I remember
you can count in january/february or
something I don't remember how many days
are in September is that the one with
less all right no I started I knew it in
my brain I knew it in my brain I knew it
in my brain see knuckle test 31 that's
how they taught us in school
clearly didn't work is I how many days
are in May oh my god stop all right
knuckle test January February March
April 31 the knuckle test fair works
every time
30 the knuckle test does that work
so August should be 31 - then if my
stinky teachers didn't mess me up the
knuckles lie have never like I know that
because that's my birthday and I am my
birthday month how many months have 31
days knuckle knuckle knuckle hey die
knuckles lie how many ones of 28 days so
it's February every other year right or
is it none I think none right oh no I
[ __ ] up yes
shut up guess how many questions are in
this quiz 100 higher well I don't know
110 higher and then 20 lower 115 lower
14 13 12 11
yeah let's see your detective skills pay
very close attention you will see the
following scene only once all right
let's do it
what color was the girl's book bag
oh god was it brown I think it was brown
no see I'm not very good at that no no I
failed I failed oh god I feel the
easiest test ever my god that's crazy
I need to look up the answers what
colors in one's bag type color could be
several cool that's great thank you so
much well that was the world's easiest
game hope you guys had fun today sorry I
apologize I had fun I don't care it's
much like subscribe and I see you guys
tomorrow hey no hey hey hey
for too long you have been farting in
the garden now you are entering a new
era where you shall craft their own poop
the hour of far spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buckells need your help
the diver you will face what crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne booty is the game to play I'm not
supposed to have my opinion about that
but the prizes
[Music]
you